Speaker 1: All right. I know that some people
don't like that. I am taking such pleasure
in the failures of Donald Trump's social media
platform, truth, social censure. But I am taking
significant pleasure in what appears to
be its imminent failure. There is yet
another obstacle now for Donald Trump's truth
social. It has been barred from Google play
over content moderation issues. This is an article
from the hill. Content. Moderation concerns
are holding up the approval of former President
Trump's truth social app on Android devices,
according to a Google spokesperson. Truth Social
CEO Devin Nunes claimed last week that the
Android version was ready and waiting. However, a
Google spokesperson said that the platform lacks
effective content moderation needed to meet
the Google Play App Stores Terms of service.
The spokesperson said, quote, On August 19,
we notified Truth Social of several violations
of standard policies in their current app
submission and reiterated having effective
systems for moderating user generated content is
a condition of our terms of service for any app.
To go live on Google Play. They don't actually
have the proper content moderation. So
this is so funny because first of all,
they brand themselves as a free speech app
saying conservatives are being silenced. There is
such demand for a real free speech app. Turns out
conservatives weren't that eager to get on truth
social, and it also turns out it wasn't really a
free speech app. If you would go on Truth Social
and you would talk about the January 6th hearings,
you would get banned. If you made negative
comments about Trump, to some degree you
would get banned. We started seeing all of
these different things, but at the same time,
the little content moderation that there is isn't
even enough to meet the standards required to be
on the Google play store, which is like the I
the I don't have an apple, the ISTORE, the IFA
iTunes store, I guess it's called. And it is
just every every aspect of this is delightful. So
my expectation is very soon, truth, social will
be done. It might remain up to make it appear as
though it's not really done. But they've stopped
paying vendors and owe their web hosting company
$1.6 million as of about a week ago. There's
almost no interaction on the platform as a as a
goof. For a little while I was posting on it, but
about a week ago I stopped because it became clear
there's just no point. It's a dead site. Even
Trump sometimes only gets a couple thousand
interactions to his posts. And the best part
about all of this is they're failing on their own.
Know nobody's censoring them. They are just not
attracting people. And it's all flailing. It's
all pathetic. It's all hilarious. And
I love absolutely every second of it.
We are going to be off on Monday for the federal
Labor Day holiday and then we're going to be
back really through the election, quite frankly.
There's Columbus Day coming up. But beyond that,
we're going to be here through the election.
We are going to be covering debates. We will
be covering election results. We will be covering,
covering rallies and so many other things. And I'm
so glad to have everybody with us. And we're soon
going to have more news about the launch of the
new YouTube channel and so many other different
things. Of course you can always sign up at join
Packman dot com. Alex Jones finds it predatory.
Speaker 3: That is a frickin predator right there.
Speaker 1: But members love it. Members love the
bonus show, they love all of it and I encourage
you to sign up at join pacman dot com you can use
the coupon code big voting 22 to get yourselves
a discount. And we will be back right
after this extraordinarily short break.
The David Pakman Show is a community
supported podcast and YouTube show and
all of those other things that it is. You can
sign up at join Packman dot com to become a
member. Memberships are a big, big deal.
Speaker 4: The bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the bonus show is one of the
great benefits and I encourage you to sign up